[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Doerr as I like to think of the Dear
John and Hank I'm back it's the podcast
where Hank and occasionally his brother
John answer your questions give you
dubious advice and bring you all of the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John how you doing I'm doing
well I'm a little tired I'm still
recovering from the last couple of
months but on the whole I am well how
are you Hank I'm good I'm also tired
you can tell by my voice that I yeah
it's a it's a tiring time of year for us
summer yeah it used to be the time of
year when we relaxed and played together
making games of our own creation
me always winning them by changing the
rules midway through even though you
despite being younger we're stronger and
smarter and more talented I I always
held the rules of the game which which
made me a winner but these days it isn't
a place where we just relax and play
games where I make the rules these days
summer is a stressful time of year where
we must play a series of games involving
rules made by other people huh and also
winter and fall and spring I feel that
winter and fall and spring are times
when I am home with my family more and I
get to make the rules in my home at
least with my wife the children don't
get to make rules and it's great fun to
control them do you have a ball
I do have a poem for today it's it's
called never again the same it's by
James Tate Hank I apologize in advance
this isn't the shortest short poem
you've ever heard in your life but I
think it's a good one okay okay all
right
speaking of sunsets last night's was
shocking I mean sunsets aren't supposed
to frighten you are they well this one
was terrifying people were screaming in
the streets sure it was beautiful but
far too beautiful it wasn't natural one
climax followed another and then another
until your knees went weak and you
couldn't breathe
the colors were definitely not of this
world
peaches dripping opium pandemonium of
tangerines inferno of irises Plutonian
emeralds all swirling and
churning swabbing like it was playing
with us like we were nothing as if our
whole lives were a preparation for this
this for which nothing could have
prepared and for which we could not have
been West prepared the mockery of it all
stung us bitterly and when it was
finally over we whimpered and cried and
howled and then the street lights came
on as always and we looked into one
another's eyes ancient caves with still
pools and those little transparent fish
who have never seen even one ray of
light and the calm that returned to us
was not even our own that's a poem by
James Tait never again the same more or
less the way that I've felt coming home
after the the last two months of crazy
travel and the the calm that has
returned to me does not even feel my own
sorry for the long short poem Hank but
it's a good one right yeah it was
wonderful it was definitely not the
lyrics to an Elton John song yeah I mean
I've noticed that in my absence
this short poems have been pretty
terrible no nothing against uh the many
wonderful guest house you've had but
they don't they don't have a gift for
short poetry yeah that's I think that's
something that you you know that you in
particular are very good at so um
remind me Hank what this podcast is all
about I know it's about AFC Wimbledon
and Mars and poetry but I believe that
there is a there is a fourth component
yes the fourth component is that we
answer questions and give dubious advice
John oh god I love dubious advice where
are we starting today Hank we're gonna
start with Russ in London who asks dear
Hank and John according to the Notes app
on my phone I have 23 books on my must
read list 25 films 6 TV shows 21 theatre
shows and 34 bands to check out on
Spotify my RSS reader shows probably 200
articles a day from web comics and video
games to philosophy and politics this is
all too much I'm piling up more
information than I can take in I'm
stressing myself out at the same time
the world is full of brilliant people
making beautiful insightful things I
love to learn about those things and I'm
really interested in lots of areas as to
crazily productive people with very
interests how do you decide what to let
through the filter so you don't get
overwhelmed ooh what a great question
from Russ we do live in an era defined
by the overabundance of information and
everything else how do we choose what to
discover in a world where there is so
much that might be discovered yeah I
don't I don't even know I'm really bad
at that actually like you I read quite
slowly so I can't even take in that much
media ID I do have a diverse set of
interests but I don't really have a
diverse set of of media consumption
habits like I watch one TV show at a
time pretty slowly
what are you watching right now I'm
watching the second season of orange is
the new black which I'm quite late to
this oh you know it's coming up at the
end of the second season of orange is
the new black
spoiler alert The Fault in Our Stars
what do you mean by that I mean that
some of the characters read and discuss
the book The Fault in Our Stars written
by me oh I think I may be I think no yes
indeed I am I am watching the third
season of orange is the new black yeah
that doesn't have anything written by me
in it but it's still good yes I I don't
know it's hard to keep track
but yes you know what I'm watching what
is the third season of the television
program the Americans oh you have heard
that because the best TV show I think
I've ever watched well you're not
helping Russ here by potentially adding
a new series to his must watch list oh
man well and the other thing that Russ
needs to do is bear in mind that Paper
Towns the movie isn't even out in the
United Kingdom yet so he needs to add
that to his list Russ I mean you need to
put aside those 25 films immediately and
focus on consuming the media that is the
Paper Towns movie adaptation yeah I mean
I think that the only thing that you can
do is to forgive yourself for all of the
amazing things that you will never learn
about and to try to focus with energy
and passion and joy on the things that
you will learn about so you know I I
don't read a hundred books
year like I used to in my early 20s but
I try to read books that I really like
and if I don't like a book frankly these
days I just stopped reading it because I
know that there's so many books on my to
read list so that would be my main
recommendation is to kind of forgive
yourself and to you know when you find
something that you like hold on to it
and get excited about it and share it
even if it means that it's gonna add to
someone else's reading list absolutely
and have it be about the process like
you know like thinking about the future
of your media consumption habits is you
know you're spending time thinking about
that rather than just enjoying the media
which is the kind of the purpose of them
just read the books don't worry about
the books that you might read and I
frankly even if we're talking about a
list that's one thing I've bought a lot
of books I haven't read and I just sit
there and I'm like wow that space Viking
book is probably really good but I
probably won't have read it yeah but
that's okay I mean the I don't know
we're all gonna die Hank as is
frequently pointed out in this comedy
podcast we're only here for a brief
glimmer of time and I don't think that
when you're on your deathbed you're
going to look back and think about all
of the things that you didn't read
hopefully you'll think about and be
lifted up by all of the things that you
did read so Russ you're gonna die and in
the meantime you might as well try to
find joy and pleasure where you can hey
can we move on to another question yes
we can all right this one is from this
this one is from Matt he writes Dear
John and Hank a friend of mine whom I
have known for years has started reading
on Rand this is terrible news
this is terrible I'm concerned about
Matt but I'm mostly concerned about
Matt's friend it's irritating for
friends and family I don't doubt it Matt
but more than that those ideas hurt
everyone and everything around whoever
spouts them so true
he's just begun this how do I help him
realize that this path is not good and
is a detriment to this planet thank you
very much it's so rare that I find
someone who hates on Rand as purely as
as Matt and I do first off thank you for
your question Matt
it's really it's moving it's profound
and it gets at the heart of the heart of
literature in in the United States which
is that iron Rand is is the worst is the
worst author in print today and you want
to talk about books that shouldn't be on
your to read list
how about you just knock off the
Fountainhead in Atlas Shrugged boom save
yourself 2500 pages I can summarize it
for you nicely which is that if you
imagine a world that is different from
the world that actually exists then
always acting selfishly would make sense
however we don't live in that world that
doesn't exist so it doesn't it you know
so so Atlas Shrugged in The Fountainhead
are both irrelevant to our actual lives
has actually lived there's something
incredibly exciting about reading on
Rand for the first time because you feel
inevitably like the characters who are
at the center of the stories you feel
like a special snowflake
you feel like you know the world is is
aligned against you and if only you know
things were fair and just and everyone
acted according to their will you would
rise to the top as inevitably you should
but the the difficult thing is realizing
that everyone experiences that when they
read Atlas Shrugged or The Fountainhead
which is precisely why those books are
so popular and still in print but yeah I
completely agree with you Matt all I can
say is that usually in time people
abandon objectivism and when they don't
you abandon them I'm just gonna leave
that one all to John because I know very
little about these books
well actually I'm super interested in
actually reading them and I would if
they were not so large because I want to
see the techniques used to make people
get so riled up about this worldview and
and so like they just like eat it so
deeply that it then for many people
affects them for their entire lives and
then you hear you know people who are
super-smart who have been affected by
this and then we could go on to become
quite successful
talking about how that these books
influence them and and I think in some
ways it it creates good business people
because it made not necess good for a
particular business because it makes
people feel very empowered in their
selfishness right right and and and so
when I when I I get I get discouraged
when I you know when I read that some
that many very powerful people have this
worldview and it's just it's it's very
upsetting because it basically requires
you to believe that most people are just
inferior are on it are inferior that is
that is that they are fundamentally less
than you you of course always being the
one who isn't inferior you the one who
has read this book ya know there's a guy
running for president of the United
States who's literally named after Iran
yeah so I think I you know this is a
place where I have especially strong
feelings and I know a lot of people
would disagree with me and I should say
because it is true that I might be wrong
and I often am wrong and you know it's
totally possible that I'm completely
wrong about Iran but I do have
incredibly strong feelings about her her
work let's move on Hank because I feel
like this comedy podcast has taken it
again a turn all right Robert asks dear
Hank and John this question is for me
apparently Hank said that he would not
go to Mars given the chance because to
be clear if for those who are listening
because of nausea and also fear of death
but if you had the chance to have a
Total Recall style memory of Mars
implanted into your brain would you of
course I would yes you would
yeah that'd be amazing that's a terrible
plan why what really have you seen the
film Total Recall like do you are you
familiar with with the movie right no
with that I was nothing to do with the
way that the memory was implanted into
his brain it was all about previous
Curren --is of his no hank things go
terribly wrong when you have implanted
memories period all the time every time
have you never read a dystopian novel
never get a memory implanted but if it
just came to me right now without
anybody else having been on Mars then I
would get to know all kinds of things
that would be new to science I would
have an obligation to science to get
this memory in please you know I was
just having breakfast with a with a
friend of a friend and we were together
recalling terrible things that have
happened to us over the years that now
feel almost like pleasurable memories
because you know like you have this you
have this wild experience that at the
time is very unpleasant I was
remembering for instance this this the
sailing trip that we took in Sweden with
with really good friends of ours and one
of him by the way is is a fan of ein
Rand and I don't know maybe a listener
to this podcast and so maybe I've just
offended him terribly but he regardless
we're still really good friends even
though we have different worldviews and
we were on this the sailboat in Sweden
Hank and it was August and and my wife
had brought a bikini and I had brought a
nice pair of swim trunks except that it
was actually like negative 45 degrees
Kelvin it was colder than absolute zero
and it was just unbelievably awful by
the way when I say degrees Kelvin people
get really mad so yeah well also when
you save below Absolute Zero
well yes exact now I've now I've know
I've I've infuriated the the Randi ins
and I've also infuriated the people who
believe in science and so really we're
down we're down to an incredibly small
audience so anyway it was it was
extremely cold in kelvins and but I
sometime I have fond memories of this
trip even though at the time I enjoyed
you know I basically spent three days
feeling cold and nauseated occasionally
playing this Swedish card game called
plump and it was generally horrific we
went to one island that was occupied by
nothing but rats but it was occupied by
so many rats it was just an inn
unfathomable number of rats per square
inch so that when you walked to the
bathroom which was the only building on
the island you would walk past literally
thousands of scurrying rats scurrying
all over your your feet which had to be
you know clothed in very very large
boots because it was so incredibly cold
in the Swedish August and and yet
somehow I I have really fond memories so
I feel like the other the other thing I
would say about you wanting to get these
memories implanted is that the memories
would in a way be a lie they would
inherently be a lie like like memory is
is incomplete and deceitful so I'm not
sure that it would be scientifically
useful that's true there is truth there
there is truth in that very very very
very very very long story that had
nothing to do with with Mars it's funny
I always make fun of you for for being
the king of tangents but in fact I just
I just did the worst I did the worst
tangent we've ever had on this entire
plot rats so many rats rats everywhere
does anyone want to hear the story of my
time
on it honest sailboat in Sweden answer
no I'll tell you anyway don't worry fear
not faithful listeners I have returned
with tales from Sweden
no 2008 i I mean I think that there are
a lot of memories that I would like to
have implanted in me like like the
memory of like we could have we could
take Russ and we could say let's just
implant the memory of having read those
25 books and you don't have to read them
ah
first off he only had 23 books on his
must read list you have a terrible
memory secondly I think with when it
comes to giving Russ advice we've gotten
way distracted and we need to focus on
the core advice which is that Russ along
with the other people of the United
Kingdom need to make sure to see the
Paper Towns movie when it comes out in
August all right John you want to give
us a question we're gonna go with this
question from Jessica Jessica writes
Dear John and Hank my boyfriend of three
years and I had a very serious
conversation recently during which we
articulated a dilemma that we both
suspected he really wants children and I
really
don't he said that at age 20 we are too
young to break up because of a potential
future issue but it's making it hard to
picture a future with him do we break up
now because of this difference or wait
to see if one of us changes our mind hmm
well first off Jessica please bear in
mind that all of our advice is dubious
yes so do not make decisions based on
our dubious advice however I have lots
of dubious advice to dispense on this
question but I'm gonna let you start
Hank oh wow well I would just say that
like it's about this person that you
have in your life and this relationship
and whether or not you want to work on
it you know and part of working on that
relationship is as coming to coming to
agreements about disagreements coming to
and if you don't feel like you can do
that then that's well but this is a big
disagreement yeah right if you don't
feel like you can come to an agreement
on the disagreement then you know it
does indeed would likely lead to a lot
of unpleasantness in the future yeah but
there are only 20 to be fair I feel like
at 20 you don't have to make a decision
for the rest of your life about having
kids agree either way yes unless you are
actually pregnant or have a child Hank
if I may tell another really long
tangential story when Sarah and I got
engaged before we got married we got
married in a Catholic Church so we had
to go to this thing the Catholic engaged
encounter which was a weekend long like
marriage counseling thing now I wanted
to run screaming from this monastery
place where we had the Catholic engaged
encounter the moment we drove up and
there were many weird and terrible
things about it but it was really useful
and a lot of things that like people
talked about that weekend or stuff are
things that Sarah and I still talk about
but anyway at one point during the
engaged encounter there were like eight
or nine engaged couples and we had to
stand back-to-back and then they said
raise your hand if you want children and
then you turned around and you saw if
your partner had their hand raised right
Sara and I were the only couple that had
had even discussed this and so there
were there were three or four really
intense fights that happened it in
public immediately after this turnaround
where one person would say to the other
what do you mean you don't want to have
children and I was like wow you guys
really probably should have discussed
this before you're Catholic engaged
encounter so in a way I'm happy Jessica
that you're talking about it now because
I didn't think that it's an important
thing and it's certainly if you're gonna
if you're gonna spend your life together
or have a long-term partnership that
goes through your child raising likely
child raising years then it's important
but like I don't think that you have to
come to any consensus when you're 20 and
I don't think that you should be holding
yourself to decisions that you make when
you're 20 if you don't have to I feel
the same way about being 37 by the way I
feel like you should be allowed to
change your mind in life and one of the
things that you know in a partnership in
a marriage is like Hank said like
figuring out how to navigate
disagreements figuring out how to
navigate different worldviews and
different priorities that will
inevitably come up in a marriage so I
wouldn't worry yet that's my opinion but
I would worry before you're Catholic
engaged encounter I'm assuming that
you're Catholic I yeah I mean there's
much there's much life ahead of you and
and it does hopefully maybe not Jessica
oh my god um it's all fleeting oh my god
you could be at the end you think you're
at the beginning but you could be in the
second half so so now that we know how
John's mind always and continually
operates it always returns to the
darkness ink at the yawning darkness
that lasts forever that awaits all of us
thanks for coming to dear Hank and John
at comedy podcast sponsored by our
friends at death death defining the
human experience for 250,000 years death
what would life be without
this podcast John I want to say is also
brought to to you the listeners by
marzipan the that the the product of
food that people sometimes shape into
other food type products and also
according to the one time that I googled
marzipan in order to to have a picture
of marzipan from Homestar Runner into
little tiny babies which is extremely
extremely creepy and there's a whole
thing on marzipan babies that I don't
know if that got shared on Facebook or
something but when you google marzipan
is likes of tiny babies the size of your
hand and it's really terrifying I guess
my concern with the marzipan sponsorship
is I just don't see how it's ever going
to be actually enacted whereas the death
sponsorship seems to me totally doable
should we answer another question I
think we should answer another question
this is from Rachel and you you used
this word earlier in the podcast and I
think that that Rachel and and everyone
needs some clarity from specifically
John Green so Rachel asks dear Hank and
John can you please explain the proper
use of nausea nauseated and nauseous
sure I will explain it nausea is a noun
like the nausea that one feels when one
is on a boat in Sweden is the proper use
of nausea and the nauseated and nauseous
are synonyms that people act like aren't
synonyms because they want to impose
rules of grammar that are ridiculous ah
is that fair heck I have no idea I had
been told that there was some that there
was some difference between those two
and by apparently these prescriptivists
d-bags yeah I mean why be
prescriptivists we all know what
nauseous means we all know it knows yet
it means technically nauseous
you know ought to mean you know a thing
that makes you feel nauseated like you
know the ocean is is nauseous when you
are on a sailboat and it makes you feel
nauseated but that's Goethe Chris we all
know what not
just means like if something makes you
feel nauseous you're it's fine it's fine
nothing nothing is going nothing
fundamental about the language is going
to is going to be deeply affected by us
just accepting nauseous also meaning
nauseated for me like language exists to
communicate and it should be as clear as
possible and when when ambiguity is
introduced from in language we need to
find ways to make it clear but like you
know all all the time we use language in
ways that are far more confusing than
nauseous and nauseated and somehow we
get by like when I say like Hank there
is a bear and it is going to kill us
you don't like pause and say but John do
you mean like a bear
person like do you mean a naked person
do you mean do you mean oh a weight that
we must bear that's going to kill us no
you just you you understand from context
that I'm referring to a large mammal
that is going to kill us and so there's
perfect clarity in that sentence so I
just I feel like we need to just let
language be unless we're introducing
problematic ambiguities you have it
there you have it from a person who
makes words for a living so we can we
can have that try very hard not to make
words I try to use existing ones not
Shakespeare and you make some words I do
occasionally make a word when I have to
have you ever have you ever coined a
word that has become you know used in
broader English the freedo the frito
maybe although I didn't coin that it
comes from my actual high school like
most of Looking for Alaska um I guess
the the word that I that I created that
is most often seen as a typo and people
email me all the time and say there is a
typo in your book Looking for Alaska is
soo a dent which refers to a a death
that is possibly a suicide and possibly
an accident
but that hasn't really caught on except
that people think it's a typo I have a
question from Jose who asks dear Hank
and John if you two could replace any
famous duo yeah who would it be and why
wait now would we in this situation
would we be becoming a famous duo no we
would yes we would be becoming Animus
doer that already exists mmm like we
would be Batman and Robin or the Wright
brothers yeah I mean not the Wright
brothers obviously because one of them
died in an airplane accident and just
knowing me it would probably be me well
in addition to that we'd have to fly
planes a lot which was something neither
of us really enjoy yeah I don't even
like being a passenger in a plane let
alone being responsible for the air
flight I'm also not really into
engineering or construction which were
the other two things that the Wright
brothers had to spend a lot of time
doing um you know John I had a dream
before VidCon that I was the pilot of a
plane and I crashed it and killed
everyone because anxiety I know what
that's a metaphor for being the pilot of
the plane that is VidCon I'm gonna say
Simon & Garfunkel
but I call Simon I'm sorry Wow I have a
beautiful singing voice I write songs
and then you harmonize with me
occasionally and then eventually I kick
you out of my band and I go on to a
wonderful solo career I have a nice not
permanent but nice marriage to Edie
Brickell of Edie Patel in the New
Bohemians and I live happily ever after
and you have very curly hair
how about Holland Oats then and you get
to be Oates
they'll take Oates I don't mind being
oats oats oats is that a good life
I actually know very little about
Holland oats except that I like their
music a great deal is that who you'd
pick you'd pick Hall and Oates
no no what would you pick what picker do
well it's let's let's replace Watson and
Crick and then not be total d-bags about
it oh that's a good idea will replace
Watson and Crick and we will acknowledge
the contributions of other scientists
especially women to figuring out the
structure of DNA and and also not be
racist that's good that's a good policy
I have to say one of the best science
books I've ever written was
unfortunately written by either Watson
or
I can't remember which one and it's
about the discovery of the double helix
and of course it's it or the figuring
out of the double helix I guess it
wasn't discovered and you know it's of
course in retro this at the time when I
was reading it in high school but it's a
it's a completely sort of fabricated
account that puts Watson and Crick at
the center of things in ways that they
really weren't but um well but it's a
good read it's not fair that you should
be able to both be a good scientist and
and a good writer but it was a it was a
good read I've never read that and to be
to be totally farad's it's Watson who
has been the the crazy sexist racist guy
I know I know let me look up and see if
it was let me see who it was that wrote
the book it was I think it might have
been I think it might have been I think
it might have been Crick let's see it
was Watson yeah I'm figured it was worth
anyway very enjoyable both still around
if he turned out later to be a d-bag I
mean so many good things are made by so
many bad people Hank this is this is
something that I've been struggling with
in general we talked about it before on
the podcast but many good things are
made by bad people Hank I have one last
question for you this comes from Presley
who you know know as the crash course
fan who really inspired us to rethink
crash course in 2012 at VidCon when she
was probably eight or nine years old and
she told us that she was using crash
course to learn history and biology and
chemistry and we that was really the
first time that we realized that crash
course could be like a proper
educational tool yeah and also that it
had a much broader demographic than we
were expecting yes much broader presley
asks if you could witness any moment of
history mmm which would you witness hmm
it's a good question it's a big question
and there's a lot of lot of things to
consider are you witnessing just like
one day or one hour or do you get to
hang around for a few years to figure
out some things that happen well I I
think Presley said moment right
precipice a moment a moment so is
some critical juncture in history that
you would like to be able to witness now
we're assuming here I think that you're
able to travel with antibiotics all the
things that you will need to prevent
yourself from getting some score you you
won't you won't you can't you can't be
hurt and you can't affect the situation
I think is implied
so the situation can't affect you and
you can't affect the situation you're
just witnessing it I love it it's a
great question I mean I think that I
would have to defer to a historian I'd
have to go to I'd have to like pull a
bunch of historians and say like what do
you guys want me to witness because I
don't know enough about this I wouldn't
I wouldn't put that decision up to me
because Who am I I'm just a video
blogger
yeah well that's actually if there are
any historians listening to this podcast
we'd love your input on this you can
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
and let us know what moment of history
we should witness because obviously Hank
and I are both yeah a little unsure on
this one right but I would love to have
like a there would be a really amazing
thing to to be there to witness Neil
Armstrong stepping on to the moon
because then I would be on and I'd like
get to be on the moon suddenly hopefully
where I could not being affected by the
entire like the lack of atmosphere or or
I could be there for the moment in
history when curiosity landed on Mars
and then I'd be there and I'd get to
watch that and that would be pretty epic
I hopefully I could bring a GoPro Oh God
it's always space with you you know why
wouldn't you go back to 2002 and be able
to witness the moment that AFC Wimbledon
Wimbledon FC the most important moment
in world history uh yeah I mean that
there's also like what would you think
about being able to witness Jesus John
oh I'd be in favor of that I think that
you could learn a lot I mean not my
initial thought was immediately went to
the the the moment that Muhammad and the
Islamic community in exile in Medina
sort of settled with the meccans to
allow a return to an annual return to
Mecca which is a critical moment in
Islamic history and one that we don't
know a ton about
that that's one moment and then the
other moment yet would be the
crucifixion of Jesus just because well
for one thing like it would establish a
lot of things about the historicity of
Jesus's life and whether there was a
Jesus of Nazareth who was crucified and
if so for what and all of that stuff I
would love to be there for that day
although I'm sure that it would be
unpleasant yes yeah those are the two
things that initially come to mind
because I am you know most of my
interest in history and understanding of
history is from you know the history of
religion but also I don't know the
moment the Buddha reached Nirvana
sitting under a tree that would be
really interesting like to watch someone
reach nirvana I don't know there's a lot
there's a lot there's a lot that I
wouldn't mind seeing from the past as
long as I could bring antibiotics the
man it'd be so cool to be able to bring
back a sample of of the but of the
biology of the day and like know more
about their flus and yeah I mean if I
could take a camera I would love to go
back in time to dinosaurs and just take
pictures of t-rex's because Henry would
freak
like that's my five-year-old so he would
freak he would if I if I was like oh
Henry I went to the Jurassic period and
here is a picture of an actual
Tyrannosaurus Rex he would flip well I
mean technically you're talking about
prehistory now I was I was thinking of
history but if we're talking about
prehistory then wouldn't she just go and
sweetness the Big Bang and be like okay
there it is
yeah I don't know I wouldn't go back all
the way back to the Big Bang I think
that I mean the Big Bang was like the
only interesting moment in the history
of time for several billion years well
you could kind of say that it was the
only interesting moment in the history
of time because time has been awfully
boring as an institution since then time
hasn't changed at all sometimes I think
about the fact that there was no time
before the Big Bang and my head starts
to hurt like when I think about how
there's supposedly no edge to the
universe can we move on ink to the news
from AFC Wimbledon and Mars your problem
there was the
before when dealing with that that you
know the creation of time right like
yeah exactly that that even that
sentence is incorrect that there was no
time before the creation of time yeah I
I it's hard to get your head around the
idea of time being created but it was it
will also cease to exist in the fullness
of time like all things let's talk about
the news from AFC Wimbledon and Mars and
now I'm wondering if time will actually
cease to exist but I'm not gonna go
there so let's talk about the forces
because everything theses eventually
even time I don't know I don't know that
that's true although I'm not sure that
we know whether or not that's true but
let me tell you some news from Mars are
you ready for it oh my god I'm so
excited all right well the Curiosity
rover celebrated it celebrated its 3rd
birthday on Mars last week though
actually on the day that this podcast is
being recorded is officially the third
birthday of the Curiosity rover on Mars
which is exciting and as we discussed
last week with Felicia
it's sang itself happy but happy
birthday today that's wonderful um
that's really lovely you know what you
know you know what else has turned three
what like a billion humans just this
year no big deal whatever now you're not
gonna impress me with turning three
curiosity well that's not actually our
Mars news which comes from an older
mission still operating in orbit around
Mars the European Space Agency's Mars
Express orbiter has been photographing
Mars for over eleven years and this week
they released a video it's really cool
it's freaking gorgeous that they
compiled from the data and photographs
collected by the Mars Express orbiter
it's a it's a 3d render flyover of
Mars's Atlantis chaos region using using
stuff from the high-resolution stereo
camera it's super super gorgeous and the
only thing I wanted from it was for it
to be longer so that I could continue
flying over the surface of Mars and you
can you can virtually fly over the
surface of Mars yourself
just got to go to youtube and search for
Atlantis chaos and that is Atlantis
chaos yes that is what it's called
that's pretty cool region of a pretty
cool planet I'm sorry I I wasn't
listening for the last three minutes
because the first minute of that was so
incredibly boring Atlantis chaos job in
AFC Wimbledon news hour-long
international worldwide nightmare is at
last coming to an end tank and AFC
Wimbledon will begin their Ligue 2
campaign this Saturday as we're
recording the podcast August 8th against
mighty Plymouth so last Saturday for the
people listening to the podcast well
yeah I guess which is a little bit
problematic because I won't be able to
know the results oh yes I'm going to
look into the future Hank and I'm going
to predict that AFC Wimbledon beat
Plymouth 3-1 two goals from audible
aachen Fenway the Beast and one goal
from George Frankenstein Franco who is a
doctor not a monster and we win three
nil and uh in the North Stand which as
you know Hank is no longer called the
North Stand it's called the John Green
stand because I'm sponsoring the stand
did I tell you about that yep you did so
and then in the North Stand after George
Frankenstein Frankenstein my name and I
will weep that is my prediction for the
game okay well I'm victory victory glory
the opposite of chaos order well in the
comments on Soundcloud or just on
twitter you can let us know how john
fared in his predictions of AFC
Wimbledon's first game of the of the
season did I say that right god we
better win you better win oh my god can
you imagine we've got to get off to a
good start Hank this is a huge deal I
mean really the good news about this
about the season starting is that now
you will have actual news to share with
us oh I thought news all summer are you
kidding the re-signing of Aachen phenoix
a hugely important thing the the
sponsorship of the north stand by noted
American
why a novelist John Green there's been a
ton of stuff happening at AFC Wimbledon
um and by the way in I would predict
three weeks the biggest and most
stunning AFC Wimbledon news ever will be
announced on this podcast and it will
definitely beat whatever your Mars news
is for that week but but it's not time
for that yet first first they have to
take on Plymouth and then on Tuesday
August 11th they're taking on Cardiff
City in the Capital One Company Cup Cup
which is very exciting as well Cardiff
City Hank a proper championship team
like they're in the second division of
football in England so it's just it's
it's an incredibly exciting time to be
an AFC Wimbledon fan but then again I
exactly I know what you're thinking Hank
it's always an incredibly exciting time
to be an AFC Wimbledon fan and that is
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon and
that is also the end of the podcast
thanks are much for listening to today's
podcast what'd we learn today Hank oh
gosh you always ask me that question and
I never take any notes oh I forget well
we learned how John feels about ein Rand
we did learn about that and we learned
that when you're 20 you don't
necessarily have to come to an agreement
with your with your partner about about
life changing huge things but you should
come to those agreements before you go
to your Catholic priest approval
ceremony thing what was that there were
there there was no priest there but yes
that's a beautiful notion what else what
else did we learn by the way neither
Sarah nor I is Catholic I should
probably mention that at some point in
the podcast which made the Catholic
engaged encounter particularly
interesting because we were learning a
lot about Catholicism while we were also
encountering our engagement you know the
other thing that we learned tank is uh
when you go to Sweden in August
don't take a bikini because it's gonna
be cold it's gonna be negative kelvins
cold oh my god we learned that negative
kelvin exists thank you so much for
listening to dear john and hank you can
leave questions for us at hand
John at gmail.com and we'll try to
answer as many as we can in the coming
weeks I'm returning for good I know that
you guys are going to miss the amazing
co-hosts that Hank his head but I'm home
for a while now which means that at
least for the foreseeable future
you're stuck with me this podcast is
edited by nicholas jenkins our theme
music is by gunnarolla you can find us
at Hank and John at gmail.com this
podcast is available wherever podcasts
are sold and as we say in our hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]